Yeah. No- yeah, I'm wearing these glasses, unironically.
I don't have my contact lenses.
I'm so sorry!
Let's make all the single fucking comments about it
and ignore the video.
Thank you very much.
It has been a pleasure.
I'll be going.
[Harry Potter music]
We are actually making the video, even though it's completely irrelevant.
Yahoo Answers.
[deep bass music]
You can ask anything in Yahoo Answers.
Some random person might answer it.
Well I thought I'll find the PewDiePie questions
(and...)
and I'll answer it!
2013.
"I was just wondering, and I'm a huge fan. Like, what started him being hated?"
"I don't get it really. Like, my friend at school say he's gay, stupid, and he- these offensive things
that got me so angry I punched him in the face."
"XD?"
Jesus Christ
"But if you could tell me in the least insulting way to him..."
I'll tell you why.
Oh boy.
Where do I even begin?
There are so many reasons. [laughs]
Number one:
I started off getting really popular way too fast.
Never good.
Never good. ;-;
Got way too many young fans watching me from the beginning.
Most of my comedy was based off screaming, yelling, yelling offensive slurs
and as soon as people started hating on me, I went and acted like the biggest fucking...
overly defensive idiot about it.
And then it just kinda took off. [laughs]
My videos are...
pretty cringy, not really that funny.
Uhm...
Just some young kid
being way more popular than he should be.
(poor felix)
[harry potter tries not to cry]
[Simple Plan music]
Let's see what the best answer is.
"PewDiePie is awesome and I love him, but
sometimes he doesn't think before he
says stuff. They can be racist or
offensive to some, also people think...." um, I think a lot before I say stuff.
It's always the question is do we leave
the joke in or do we edit it out?
I really appreciate offensive jokes but
a lot of people don't and uh it's just how
you do it.
Sometimes you can pull it off, sometimes
you can't and uh people um people are way
too sensitive. [laughs]
"Also, people think his screaming is
annoying,
in fact that he fails to be funny."
*realizing its true*
Yeah. [laughs] Who is better PewDiePie or
TobyGames.
Oh yea, back in the day people
would compare me to Toby Turner a lot,
because we both played happy wheels, but
I've always clearly been better (at relationships)
That's right, Toby. [kissy face]
"Do you watch PewDiePie?"
"Yes brofist." - "Hell no pewdiepie is a huge
massive ARSE hole
all he cares about is subscribers!"
Fucking hell do people really have time
to write this shit?
"PewDiePie's channel has just SUB4SUB4SUB4SUB."
[laughs]
*high pitched voice* "He only cares about subscribers."
Stupid kids, kids are so dumb.
"Who is the worst YouTuber on YouTube?"
"Best answer - PewDiePie."
[Simple Plan music]
Oh man, come on internet when are, when are
you going to cut me some slack?
What did, what did I do to you come on man
come on come on. Who is this person?
Come on Dex, come on Dex. "Likes to help
accounting problems," or "What's a good mang-."
Alright, let's, let's judge you here, alright let's
see here.
"What are some good anime / manga ?" Alright, let's see what you recommended.
Oh so you recommend "Sword Art Online,
Code Guess." All- mainstream anime alert!
Mainstream anime nerd alert! Alright
this has been fun!
Wow this is going great guys. This is
going really good.
I really feel confident about this, this
video
"PewDiePie VS Markiplier - Who do you think
is better?" - "I think PewDiePie is better,  because
he's more funnier than markiplier, but markiplier
is awesome too."
[Music playing]
That's right, Mark.
What are you gonna to do? What are you gonna cry? *next roast video*
[Roast video]
[laughs] Oh my God.
[laughter continues]
[Dramatic music in background]
[Dramatic music continues]
[Dramatic music intensifies]
"PewDiePie is in the top most handsome men."
"Really there must be something wrong with it."
[More dramatic music]
Ohhh! Hey Norman Reedus you got fucked by
poodiepie bitch oh!
OHHH!
Who's the most handsome?
"Where does PewDiePie live?"
They actually
fucking added my old address in Italy
[claps]
Nice! Nice invasion of privacy.
Yeah I'm sure you'd like that to happen to
you huh. That'd be fucking great.
"Why is PewDiePie the number one
YouTuber when he just posts himself
playing games?"
Because that's what you think.
People will take something - they'll make it into the smallest thing and
then be like "WHY, I don't understand."
Maybe if you looked a little deeper than
that if you think I just post videos of
myself playing games,
then you're a fucking idiot.
But don't worry about it.
Still love ya, please subscribe.
Alright,  this has been Yahoo Answers PewDiePie edition.
Thank you so much for watching, if you learned
something new leave a like
you can leave a like anyway, because that way I get
more likes. Subscribe if you're not a bro
already and I will see you tomorrow with
the new video as every fucking single
day
how about that. ...alright.
Thank you bros so much for watching, and
as always stay awesome bros.